une série télé réalité tout ce qu'on ne
vous a jamais montré sa langue au baiser
mais c'est quoi cette équipe de [ __ ]
sois patiente à peine deux heures qui
sont dans le château
bon en fait entre le premier
tu souris toujours qu'on a des villes
chez comptant alors à de s'ouvrir bon
allez pas nous ton ressenti alors je
suis vraiment content par mois rien là
qui généra
panon bas les profs sont super cool j'ai
sorti mon bar graisseuse et aujourd'hui
nous sommes témoins de baisers
lequel tu veux te taper moi franchement
dans savages content tu vois se passe
bien tranquille pépère tu nous courons
sur dix a dit qu'il chantait comme un
pied en plus il a dit que tu fais pitié
avec ta casquette pas franchement là du
70 ha ouais mais quel est ce là je te
jure mais qu'à moi je la prends je
l'appelle à des fonds cela retombe de
singles [ __ ] en plus une ancienne
stripteaseuse sur ma vie je voulus pour
hirson prime
je suis extrêmement content d'être ici
c'est pas trop dur d'avoir abandonné son
fils et son mari de plantes fils et mon
mari me manque je veux plus
je voudrais vraiment remercier rompu
ludique de m'avoir sauvé lors du prime
et pourquoi tu crois qu'il t'a sauvé
battant en baisse est clair parce que je
donne tellement à bout vin qu'il a
réussi à truquer du coup peu
mélodieux tu peux pas dire ça aboie
bas le public m'a sauvé et je tiens
vraiment à la remercier du fond de mon
coeur
ça veut pas ça si tu veux tu veux sortir
s'il te fais je crois qu'il faut qui
t'appelle je crois qu'il travaille pas
aujourd'hui si
j'aimerais trop sortir mon album
des gaffes parce que si on dit fiston
passage qui risque de passer au zapping
ouais non
aaa
par contre j'ai pas eu le temps en
apprendre mon texte alors hier on a
passé une soirée on appuie que les cov
des troncs non ça tu peux pas le dire
vous picoler ah ouais je passe bien
après vous donner en temps depuis que je
fais pas tiens tu bosses et la cgt non
non tu fermes ta gueule est sinon
faudrait nous redonner des capotes parce
que là on est un peu grave en rade quoi
et sinon c'est quitter idole on me les
donne bah moi tu vois je suis plutôt rap
old school tu vois ce genre baby baby
bien sûr alliance ethnik juste heureux
avec moi tout le monde on en sait moins
c'est dit l om qu'elle informe qu'un
sonia es tu là je représente le ghetto
raconte vous montrez pas les vidéos je
me fais quesnel ses futurs ouais c'était
ce matin j'ai pas le temps de trancher
nos mines à qui ça bah celui qui l'a
kent mais je peux passer une meilleure à
la [ __ ] maman c'est pour toi ça
maintenant
la cartouche que j'ai mis à chaque débat
s'était progressivement
je me retiens je me retiens c'est un
homme solide je suis désolé non mon
comprends c'est au brésil facile
la
sicav ça passe [ __ ] j'ai besoin de
chanter moi j'aime bien chanter se
présenter eux
c'est pas moi qu'il faut regarder c'est
c'est la caméra
c'est ce que je fais alors regarde moi
moi
elle était vu leurs gardes
dans la jungle
et sinon tu comptes le gagner comme en
prime ah ben moi j'ai de beauty tchèque
c'est quoi le petit chèque et connaît
pas le witsec ben regarde tu fais comme
ça
mais avec tes fesses ça bloque belote
c'est trop beau quoi
d'un casier judiciaire ouais non pas
face non oui pas vraiment quoi parce que
moi une fois c'était pas loin
j'ai fait un truc de bâtard
j'ai conduit sans permis
et sinon vous n'amenez quand l'animal
dans la piscine on attend l'accord des
services vétérinaires as tu préfères
allure club rapide
tu sais quoi